so you fulfilled all your contracts and
completed all your challenges and now
you want more hitman well I've got good
news about episode 2 the game's official
Twitter account has revealed the release
date and you'll be able to enjoy hit
man's second episode on April 26 hit man
episode 2 takes place in the fictional
Italian town of sapienza that means
wisdom in English by the way and you'll
need to be wise as you take out new
targets in the densely packed town but
that's not all that's coming to hit man
patch 1.03 is available as of today
March 31st it improves load times
especially for the Paris level and fixes
some other issues that were leading to
game crashes it also includes the new
vampire magician challenge pack which
adds 10 new missions centered around one
of paris's goofier costumes the update
is available on ps4 and Xbox one and
should be coming to PC very soon
according to developer IO Interactive
looks like agent 47 will have plenty to
do in the month of April for now you can
stay tuned to gamespot for all the
latest in the world of hitman
you